and Bret the rumor mill is working
overtime here on potential staff changes
remaining at the White House you
remember the other day and last week the
president suggested that there are more
changes ahead we don't know if these are
going to happen but we are told that
there could be a bloodbath if not
tomorrow then Friday at the latest in
the top of the changes I'm being told to
watch for HR McMaster the National
Security Advisor to be out to be
replaced by Ambassador John Bolton
another potential change coming up VA
secretary David Shulkin out to be
replaced by energy secretary Rick Perry
the Rick Perry has been telling people
that he is is will and likes it over at
energy and really isn't not inclined to
move over to the VA possibly replacing
Perry at energy would be the private
overseas Private Investment Corporation
Chairman ray Washburn and another
possible departure that's rumored this
one may be further off John Kelly to
potentially be replaced by OMB director
Mick Mulvaney some people I've talked to
say that the president may be in a
position where he simply wants to rip
the band-aid off and get this all done
in one fell swoop other people are
saying well some of these cabinet
changes may take a little longer than
say swapping up your national security
adviser there was one addition to the
White House today after days of it being
rumored the president announced the new
head of his National Economic Council
great in an interview with his current
employer business channels CNBC Larry
Kudlow today confirmed he will be the
president's new chief economic adviser
we're gonna get on the infrastructure
yeah we're getting it on the trade also
he's completely in command and as he
always does not only does the explain
stuff he's thinking but he asked
questions if I try to you know give him
the Kudlow
the Kudlow thing he's gonna come back
and he's a smart man while President
Trump and Kudlow don't see eye to eye on
every issue they have known each other
for decades Kudlow was one of president
Trump's earliest supporters during the
campaign believing in tariffs says also
in negotiating quick reaction from
business was glowing the National
Association of Manufacturers saying
President Trump has chosen a tremendous
advocate for free enterprise and
competitiveness in the United States to
lead his economic team one potential
pitfall with the white house process
under a microscope can Kudlow get a
security clearance in the early 90s he
had a significant addiction to cocaine
and alcohol for many prospective
employees that could be a deal-breaker
but it was a long time ago Kudlow went
through treatment and he says he's been
sober ever since my life has had twists
and turns with God's grace I'll have 23
years clean and sober in another person
he'll move Jeff Sessions is considering
whether to fire FBI deputy director
Andrew McCabe McCabe left his post at
the FBI January 29th but his official
retirement date is Sunday the FBI office
of Professional Responsibility
recommended two sessions that McCabe be
terminated because of negative findings
at a pending inspector general's report
if McCabe is fired by close of business
Friday he could lose hundreds of
thousands of dollars in retirement
benefits in a statement DOJ spokeswoman
Sarah is go Flores told Fox News the
department follows a prescribed process
by which an employee may be terminated
that process includes recommendations
from career employees and no termination
decision is final until the conclusion
of that process President Trump made no
mention of the staffing issues today his
only public appearance at tax reform
roundtable at the plant where Boeing
makes f-18 jet fighters the president
again tilting toward the possibility of
another tax cut we're actually going for
a Phase two which
in addition to middle-class will help
companies and it's going to be something
I think very special president Trump so
far has a relatively low-key day on the
schedule for tomorrow the one public
appearance he had so far he's meeting
with the irish t shook that is the Irish
Prime Minister Lee over at Kerr for the
annual st. Patrick's Day visit but you
can bet Brett all eyes are going to be
on the president's personnel file
watching for the next move well watch it
closely in coming days John thank you